[Musique]
la gloire implique nécessairement de
grandes responsabilités
[Musique]
quand on connaît comme moi le véritable
succès on devient qu'on le veuille ou
non un exemple pour les générations
futures
[Musique]
je rappelle thomas lebrun je suis
chorégraphe v6 my story
[Musique]
tout a commencé au conservatoire alors
que j'étais encore qu'un petit garçon a
little more est déjà à l'époque personne
ne pouvait nier mon incroyable potentiel
de danse art
[Musique]
4 6 7 8
je
[Musique]
thomas on n'est pas dans un cours de
support ici
[Musique]
[Rires]
mais en tant qu'artiste tenez je ne
voulais pas brider la créativité
débordante
je voulais vivre toutes les passions
pleinement comme le stylisme par exemple
[Musique]
là encore j'ai été béni d'un indéniable
trent
[Musique]
mais très vite
very soon j'ai décidé de me concentrer
sur mon unique vocation avec en prime la
noble tâche de transmettre mon art est
l'ultime récompense du partage
[Musique]
passez-vous parallèle regard loin
traverse le mur
[Musique]
m
ah ah
ok
ouais
[Musique]
les auteurs du genre contrat famille
soul de ma gueule
[Musique]
après avoir dansé avec les plus grands
chorégraphes je décidé avant tours
d'embrasser cette première carrière
[Musique]
même si la modestie m'impose de terre
l'immense succès de mes oeuvres je dois
bien admettre qu'il peut parfois être
grisant de recevoir tout l'amour de son
public et une telle reconnaissance de
ses pairs comme disait le poète un moyen
tout le monde l'a fait quoi hier il ou
raphaël on a mis à rigoler
et bien maintenant passons aux choses
sérieuses
[Musique]
dans toutes les pièces que j'ai pu faire
il ya toujours un rapport à la mémoire
la transmission c'est peut être des
pièces avec beaucoup d'humour avec
beaucoup de décalages mais cette pièce
là sur hiroshima on est vraiment sur
l'idée d'une transformation de la
mémoire et qu'est ce qu'on en retient
aujourd'hui d'un événement pareil
les images j'ai eu des reportages et les
livres tout ça ça m'a questionné sur
comment la mémoire se transmettait et
comment elles s'effacent et comment
elles pouvaient se déformer et qu'elle
est aussi du coup l'importance de la
mémoire
oh
[Musique]
non
les gens ne sont jamais contents les
gens ont toujours un problème
il est toujours quelque chose de grave
qui leur arrive mais ce qui arrive des
kilomètres et des kilomètres
quelque part on n'a même pas envie de le
voir mais ils n'ont rien vu c'est soit
parce qu'ils n'avaient pas la
possibilité de voir quelque chose ou
soient pas ce qu'on peut on peut dire je
n'ai rien vu parce que je n'ai pas eu
envie de voir
[Musique]